okay for people joining this livestream
this is our monthly documentation
meeting well we're talking about a
variety of topics related needless to
say to documentation okay let's talk
about the route guide page on the web um
okay what are we looking at here okay so
what am I gonna do here yep any of those
this was one of your ideas to have it
not quite the full span of the tile yes
Jeremy hell I am it doesn't look that
connected to me I'm not good no no I'm
not loving this maybe some border there
but this is definitely better it makes
up to the you know the the structure of
the page like it's it's actually an
overlay but it looks like it's a unit of
the page is the problem what about
bringing yellow bringing a yellow border
down around here yeah that would help
can we try them real-time
does anybody here could try that
Thanks okay oh cool
guide link over is this real I met it's
just a mock-up but it was Heidi's idea
based on the other fat tooltips we were
doing for usages if it doesn't have a
load time problem I love it
well we do plan to lazy load those
things so this this would be too if we
did it now I don't know if you would
want more to scroll up for the rest of
the list link off or link off to the
page there little more at the bottom
some of these are gonna be a lot longer
than others so well I think it's gonna
indicate if it goes longer but I think I
mean I don't see you're not going to be
able to deep click
an individual function are you here are
you know what I do this looks like a
preview maybe you might be fooled into
thinking you could but I don't think
that's what we're building I mean could
could we in fact deep link into an
individual function though I was
assuming we would actually why not yeah
if you can read it if your eyesight is
good enough maybe this is probably a
large desktop view feature yeah I agree
it's very nice I has to go a pretty
quickly let's see it what you play I
like this I mean I think you're three
column all the way down to almost 600 so
that would technically work it would
just get pretty small at small widths
you know between six and eight hundred
it's gonna be pretty tiny I assumed it
would be gone by then well it could go
tiny just to give you a sense of scope
but um but then have a pure clique you
know just cut to the page type thing
just the orange those are really useful
you don't even need the function names
in some cases maybe we could just you
know when it gets narrower what suppose
yeah yeah I I kind of like having the
function names even if they're really
small you could have a differentiation
between the sizes so that these are just
blobs and these so you don't imagine
you're gonna click on them because
they're just a blob but it gives you
some sense of how many functions there
are there yeah so Owens
when did the window the rest of the
tiles gray out is that only when you
mouse over or is that when you've
clicked core language and structure yeah
they I've made them a little gray
probably on the mouse over or maybe not
because you needed a differentiation
between the two pods
this one going gray it's just slightly
gray I really meant the the the rest of
the tiles the data manipulation and
analysis and everything else oxd yeah
they're like bugs town that seems okay
but I'm guess I'm wondering
is it a natural transition to go to this
being slightly gray I guess it is if
these ones are going full gray
and it's okay to lightbox down these
these top tiles but not lightbox down
the the other tiles on the page I don't
think I'd do that I'd lightbox down
everything yeah that was kind of an
oversight okay
but that lightbox effect occurs only
when you started mousing over the sub
items and you get this you know you get
the the preview pop-up or is it when
you've clicked core language and
structure to power I mean I don't know
why I mean in this case for example one
could you know that would absolutely be
a way of distinguishing this is to
ah gray out the background
let's grout the background that way you
absolutely know you click that and as
soon as you move off it well ok then
you've got the weird case of you're
moving to something that is grey well
you could grab down slightly or you
could punch up this tile somehow but I
don't know be worth trying to grey down
the other one slightly I think what does
Jeremy think no I'd like that lightbox
effect I'm wondering when the thing goes
away mentioned is it when you Mouse out
or is it you click to make it close back
up well yeah I think you have to click
to make it close back up you do not want
it going away otherwise you've got that
crazy thing we have oh I know yeah
that's what I was worried about by the
way this effect of a partial tile is
good when it hits a full tile it's a bit
weird but we could always force it to be
a partial tiles you know height add some
weird bottom padding in some cases it'll
look like a mistake you know I don't
know prime so the bordering is the
better idea so let's see what we can get
with bordering yeah you shift refresh
that page there's a little there's a
little bit of a border there now but the
lightbox takes care of that too I don't
know why but I went to the wrong URL if
you want to click it again
yeah I saw that little border well it's
the bigger for me when I shift refresh I
don't know why it went to the wrong page
for you though but again I almost don't
even need the it's good but the borders
I think the light box is more important
than the border okay
you're seeing a different Buddha yeah
I've seen this one it's there but it's I
think the light box is really what
connects it right everything will fall
back and you're just gonna look at sound
and I like the border though I mean that
the border is good it's fine I think the
light box is really gonna do what we
need okay but don't like books it too
much otherwise people will think they
can't move anywhere yeah let's try it is
that the su is that something you could
try I think that might take a bit more
work but I can see if I can get it okay
wonderful
okay Brian our live stream is pointing
out that if we if these are not
clickable they shouldn't be the same
blue I don't know oh yeah that's partly
true but if they're really just blobs
I kind of agree I kind of agree that
they should drop down to some other blue
or some other grayer color
slightly subtle now we didn't discuss
the more button down here do we in fact
have long enough pages that that's an
issue
just go to the page you get no benefit
after you click you might as well just
go to the page and back up if it's not
what you want by the time you clicked
yeah right there nice your question of
page length even I mean language
overview actually does have a section
pass what's shown here so it's just one
but it's not infeasible for okay by the
way the separators this will have
separators on it on the page right
you're not you're not stripping the
separators here
no I think it was just lost in the
mock-up if that's the case son or
actually aren't any on the page like
there are no I was thinking no
separators separators you're gonna get a
lot of lines that way it could be very
line line line
well we gotta see it oh there's one
oh well yeah those separator I like it
yeah
Heidi I assume that's just like a
screenshot of the page right at a
certain width yes exactly
yeah okay um what do we do with the more
I love the look of this this is a great
idea Heidi um well I got a couple of
minor comments okay
is the the kind of the way that it comes
out at the right but having such a long
distance between the I'm just a little
concerned about how you connect that
background hover right instead I mean
you could highlight the text but the
background hover as a bar would connect
it up
I'm saying despair I see I see you have
it you have a background bar that's all
the way across to the to the speech
bubble thing yeah okay okay what are we
doing a lot more um the more could have
Agia may instead of a down arrow and
just go to the page yes but we go to
indicate how much more there is I think
I would love to say plus two sections
plus one section or something is that
feasible it's just yeah it's just
counting headings on the page so maybe I
mean if some other indication of how
much more there is yet could be like
another twenty functions in the section
you're seeing that could be yeah I was
thinking we could even do thumbnails
there see whether you can make that work
you can make that work
you
you
is this only doable only Brian is this
how would this work in product the other
tooltips we said were web-only
yeah we don't this is a lot of roll your
own getting mouse over hover that way
okay I think we should concentrate on
the web for this and see how it does
that
okay let's move on so we're gonna do a
couple more experiments on that more
button and otherwise let's what we can
see it in the design meeting maps I
added a slight overlay for when you cool
okay which one demo to a demo one demo
to
that's nice look lovelies that's pretty
cool yeah lovely well done that was
quick I have to click on sound again
okay alright so that needs to be fixed
that's that sure yeah I think the hover
should be full brightness too when you
hover over like strings right yeah that
should light up yes this is racist yeah
and um oh you didn't do it he didn't do
it for everything you're a couple
so you didn't that these ones would have
an orange border right they would
continue that color yeah yes great okay
on would like to go meta livestream
cross-linking ice creams to that yeah so
if there's a new live streams icon there
on the rights hey why don't we do a
trust effect we can we can link this
live streaming life to the anyway I mean
do you want these unrelated links once
before you had talked about putting
design history GMA after the history
footer section but that's getting quite
a bit longer now that we have the
modified in full history there and then
also some of these symbols have multiple
live streams that we'd be linking to so
I just want to know the best way to do
that
you
oh that isn't real I hope hope no no
these this is just a layout of the icons
that were approved before and then the
livestream one there on the right is
what we were suggesting if we put these
livestream links in the related links
section
why wouldn't we I don't see any reason
not to I mean so long as landing pages
for the live streams look sensible and
make clothes they have dates on them on
things okay it's about the idea that if
a function had more than one live stream
it would have a landing page that had
that would link to each of its live
streams and is that something that we
get for cheap or is that something that
somebody's gonna have to well I think
what we should do okay I mean we're
planning for a different project to
annotate live streams because what we've
got with the new video capabilities in
version 12.1 we should be able to
automatically scan the video of these
live streams so even though we're going
to try and make you know half a dozen
thumbnails from each live stream so that
you can tell roughly what will happen in
it okay together with the plan is to run
speech recognizer and see if we can
generate some word clouds from them yeah
they'll be interesting okay and they
also have titles so my tendency is to
think that every live stream will end up
with a home page um the and so then when
this has live streams maybe this can
open what could you do here see I don't
know how many they'll be for any given
function for a guide page that I mean
like like four you know I don't know for
the database functions there are a
painfully large number right there's
probably 15 for those should we put
these on guide pages or just on symbols
I who I wouldn't want to put them on
guide pages okay as long as there's a
reasonable landing page for that guide
page you know if if each symbol on a
guide page has
you know five livestreams they're two
different things here actually there's
three things
um so there's a different kind of live
stream which is the presentations that
you know like the new in version 1204
people have done those will be really be
worth linking here honestly those are
probably more worth linking here than
the design live streams right and if
there's other Wolfram You content and so
on it is really important to link here
so I mean the I'm kind of thinking that
there needs to be humph
look how are we doing when there's
multiple data repository entries what do
we do um uh what do we do with that and
the serrated links thing do we list each
data repository entry I mean when you
say repository here that is really the
name of a data repository entry right I
believe so I I'm not sure it's not that
common and I don't think that we have
data repository links from Docs but we
in that case I would think it would be
one one repo item per link okay so fine
I'll talk to Brett
I don't understand you're saying the
link would say data repository no
absolutely not
it would say it would have a it would
have that icon and then it would say you
know meteorite impact you know whatever
the name of the data repository item is
yet there wouldn't there still be
something that says data repeating Rin
Pike's impacts in the Wolfram data
repository or something like that
okay can we be specific here because
this is very obscure I'm confused
that first one is an example in that
list under if that's not a real example
it's demonstrations with four
list or something is that right well I
think it it's meant to be
that's demonstration title and
underneath you have paren Wolfram
demonstrations project right that's the
okay is it a specific demonstration no
that's why it's a sir it's a search
query okay so what let's be specific
okay we don't know what's it can you
show me a specific example of this okay
okay let's move on and we'll come back
to this okay
I did it's it's not with demonstrations
but with fast introduction and an
elementary introduction we preface both
of those link texts with the title of of
that website I don't understand what
you're talking about I want to know is
this linking to a specific demonstration
or I already told you that that's
linking to a search query to all the
demonstrations that use function okay
what about linking to neural net
repository okay I will come back to that
one I'll find one
Brian do you know
Brian here I I am I I don't know I've
top my head it's whatever
so listen listen listen what what I
think in most cases these subsidiary
links could have multiple items in them
like the neural net repository there
might be five neural Nets I don't think
we want to gum up this page we're
listening five separate neural nets I'll
say that I found the net model page has
a link to just the neural net repository
homepage right which I think probably
makes sense cuz it's okay so then what
we really want is to say networks in the
neural net repository okay for another
page let's say it's for facial features
or something okay
networks in the neural net repository
and then what I think we should do is
some kind of pop out you know pop-up
menu that lists the particular ones so
like it's a micro guide page do you get
what I'm saying yes yes so rather than
five separate bullets for each of those
things you have one for yeah and then it
pops up that's what I'm thinking with
the live streams we could say design
live stream you know December 3rd 2019
design live stream blah blah blah say
presentation
you know live stream and we list the
presentation ones first
okay list them an inverse chronological
order most recent first in general and
presentations before design ones that's
what I think we should do and each one
then clicks to the home page of that
live stream which could be a YouTube
page it could be an embedded page okay
it will be an embedded page once we have
all the stuff with with them a new
project you were talking about you mean
but but by embedded page you mean a page
on our site under documentation or do we
mean well it's a page on the site under
live streams
and we have such a page now that isn't
directly associated with you is that
correct I don't believe that's correct
yet yeah okay that's what I believe that
needs to come yeah because we're gonna
have separate ones like for the physics
project and things like that okay okay
you
let's see someone is asking for embedded
video in a notebook ah you should've
been here for another recent livestream
it is coming into 0.1 excitingly um okay
updated in separators so this is yeah at
the very bottom heidi has some options
there for you we're looking at these yep
and in those ones at the bottom they we
had them separated just by commas you
wanted to look at other options to
separate the full updated in history
well - is is show not gonna work that's
like November knows what that means
commas look weird
I don't know these bullets look okay a
little with the point decimal points
Jeremy any ideas I think be the the ones
that cycle between decimal points and
not decimal points bothers me more but
the bullets look good but somehow you
get down to like ten nine six it's
looking odd like I'm not diversions but
but that's also because Heidi is listing
them out of chronological order it would
never look like that
okay always be six nine ten whatever
they're also sort of years in Firenze
after each okay well then oh really
that would help oh I missed that we're
gonna have to come back to this then
okay can you remark that and we'll come
back to it yep okay and can you mark it
with them in numerical order
ah okay vertical responsiveness big
topic so I gave you some screenshots if
if opening this is is annoying but I
also give you buttons that opens it at
the right Heights we just don't want to
miss suggesting critical separator bombs
but we're kind of using that for the
difference between introduced in and
update it in um yes and blam is also
suggesting earlier account of the lines
not showing in the in the guide pages
possibly let's see if we can get a see
if we can do something more with with
the you know what another
thing we could do maybe too cutesy is a
kind of a an icon of a page that shows
you know partially what can I say that
that shows like the whole page it could
be quite long but it like one of these
icons here and then it shows some part
of his white and some part of it is
grayed off and then it has a grill of
May or something maybe that's to isolate
obscure Jeremy do you understand what
I'm talking about I do but it to me it
only works when the icon is big enough
yeah okay I'm not sure how it works in a
small space like the bottom of that
right that little bar at the bottom yeah
fine I mean the problem is with the bar
at the bottom you know I think it should
just have lots of arrows you know big
arrow down and then move or something
and then you click it you need to grill
am i ah
the problem is that it's a the the bar
is a very horizontal thing and yet where
you're trying to indicate it's a lack of
vertical stuff and that's awkward
okay vertical responsiveness all right
what are you gonna show me here what is
this um this is just a compare the what
happens at the different heights okay so
what am I supposed to do I suppose we
could open up all three or you could
just open up the example screen let's I
keep it nice and wide no don't don't
change the width just right
okay one more why doing I'm changing
just click the other two buttons as well
so leave this one yeah and then you can
compare all three finally it made it 600
heights what a computing web execute
yeah that's fancy yeah okay and so then
there's another breakpoint at 400 the
other button it's better to just use
your mouth and resize the window well
that's magnificent but what does it mean
I just put them side by side and you can
see that it's already reducing white
space and lowering font sizes oh yeah so
you should scroll down the page and see
the different sections there's probably
more white space we can reduce but we
should talk so you're saying on this
page if I go to do that's the real
effect yeah there you go that's cool so
the but the most important place where
this appears is in the sidebar on the in
the cloud I mean yeah that's the
prominent use case a Saints what why is
that important because you end up seeing
in the cloud you end up seeing only
super structure and no content and some
of the documentation that's not a short
I know that it's both narrow and short
in the cloud with a small height I mean
you're not well look it it worked for
Stevens you know no but that's Aero
narrow but I don't think it did it
it already did this it was the youth
case that we were inventing this for
this is this is vertical responsiveness
the issue yeah yeah I remember what the
issue is the issue is in the cloud when
you have multiple sections in the
sidebar okay you get the stupid thing
that when you are making the sidebar of
low vertical height that you there are
three sections there but they don't
they're not responsive vertically so you
end up seeing only the top section which
tried to grab a lot of height did that
make sense
I understand it but I know how you get
in that position right how do you get
into that state a we get in that state
in a bunch of the scarring plants ah the
rodeos do that don't you so maybe the
mooks
would get into this case I can see that
you know the panel's you know you could
have a panel cases where you know we're
not putting documentation pages in the
mood panels okay what did we invent this
for we wanted Stephen you mentioned the
onboarding page is probably yes a lot of
stuff on the sidebar it's not acumen
Terrell it's narrow with not small
height I mean the Doc's tend to be its
own overlay right you'll have stuff on
the sidebar and then if you choose Doc's
it replaces what's in the sidebar
completely okay so listen
documentation lists builds in the future
like people would be using only the web
Doc's and they'd probably want to
position their windows on the screen
right but we had a much better reason to
do this and it had to do with the web
the cloud case but doesn't matter if
we've done it so let me see in this case
here so the point is that you've
squashed these up in some way is that
right yeah yeah if you compare it to the
tall one over there on the right there's
somewhat reduced white space yeah it's
nice so you could have stacked windows
right you can have your documentation
above in your notebook below if you want
that and they would work better you
could reduce the white space around
those dividers a little bit more that's
what I was thinking yes all right but
this is a nice thing we don't completely
know what it's for there was a good
reason there's a there's a really maybe
the notes would reveal how dig through
yeah right there was a really good
reason to do this but since we've done
it let's just be happy
um what about guide pages they do that
on guide pages as well I think I'll have
to look at those separately good all
right complaint from Ali on our live
stream their functions at some time to
take extra arguments and those extra
arguments and not
documented please give us some example
generally they should they tell if
unless we put them in as some very
experimental thing they should be
documented so give us an example please
okay ready to go to tech notes
yeah these finally so okay so what is it
what are we asking is this so you'd pick
some colors last time that we talked so
heidi mocked up of a tech note in in
that scheme and we just we really want
to approve a design so we can get to
implementing them
don't we have something else in teal or
clothes see that on the right there oh
you can't be serious those are not
different enough cuz I think that's why
there are more options
you
Jeremy I need your help here I didn't
see that as the work flow color at all
to me that's blue a nut deal
well I barely know distinctly see the
work flow color is different but this is
a nice color yeah purple is a nice yeah
the purple ooh blue is kind of nice as
long as it doesn't look like a link I
would call that violet all right yeah
you go go with this it seems definitive
as well and what's this this is tealing
things that's the jump link the top so
chevrons instead of double Chevron's I
see looks a lot like a bird walked along
the beach there oh is this an extreme
case that number of items is this
typical Brian um it's maybe a little
high it's not this is it's odd-looking
with all this if there were six in
decline I think what we have here looks
bad but I don't know if we need to
optimize for it
I wouldn't be surprised if 10 is pretty
common okay without having without
actually having running the run numbers
okay I smaller you know half the size I
think we'd be fine that sounds good to
me
um okay about a that's the design as far
as content content is moving along just
as we discussed I think I'm I think I
need to do about five or six more
sections in the book there were a few a
few issues with the content with some
content that was merged into tutorials
for version six and I need to find a way
to split them appropriately or duplicate
the content and it's but it the content
is almost in so the design was once we
get this approved then this will be just
about wrapped okay can we look at
captions there was a couple other things
here unless the way by the way Brian I'm
wondering whether we should put
something somewhere maybe at the very
end that says this was based on material
from you know the mathematical book just
because for people who I don't know
whether it's worth that context but it
is a little I mean it isn't always true
though no it's only when it is true I
mean some of it still is whatever so
timeless I guess I mean so long as it's
really timeless you know in other words
we get some benefit from saying it was
in this book 30 years ago and we also
get some you know like if it's time I
don't know I don't know Andre I go what
you're saying where it's not only does
that make it clear that it's a little
but potentially long in the tooth but it
also kind of shows off that you know
they it still works yes right well do
are we not gonna use the notes about
when the information was added right
that was part of the original spec and
there was something in the header and it
still never made it in but okay well so
let's look at that please and then we
could say it's from you know based on
stuff from the Mathematica book editions
you know one through five I put those
back okay fine this really sucks that
that doesn't there's a whole bunch of
options on the right you had said last
time the captions were all wrong great
because we've sort of sans font going
for everything well earth will be go you
know serif for this okay well we had a
sans font before you so it was all wrong
maybe it's just cuz it was the lite
version I think the real problem was
that it was very hard to read it as part
of this you know as the I mean this made
a lot more sense when it was in a
printed book so you know it somehow got
to attach to this as it's the caption
for that as opposed to it's a floating
piece of text that you know escaped from
the block of text below why is it a
caption and not a like a light heading
I just don't parsed very well no I don't
get it either but what do you mean by
heading on yeah above ya heading on top
it doesn't have to be really heavy but
it seems like it belongs above well the
problem is they were all written to go
below and I don't guarantee that none of
them will fail going above Brian might
be able to comment on that I mean I
can't I can't spirit up the text of each
and every one of these
but that would have been my concern to
that can we find a graphic-design device
where they can go below but still be
attached I mean like for example what
would happen if we had them in the box
Boxster cab - you could tap it bring it
bring an additional frame down right
yeah but it's got the frame line yes I
know the gate can be white it'll
emphasize it too much and also it's got
that giant amount of white space there
but when I bring the whole frame down
below and have a very light frame in the
middle
you know if it was had the box I would
rather it was at the top of the box okay
then quick we can't put it at the top of
the box constraint content constraint so
design wise what can we do I think
tabbing it'll look awkward you know the
the the the little tabby thing coming
out there will look awkward unless we
unless we had a device we could round
the tab I suppose yeah look how about
just in the box maybe with the divider
line or something that's what I said and
everybody said it was terrible it was
terrible but I think it won't work cuz I
think there'll be too much space on the
right I think I think it won't read as a
caption I think it'll reduce piece of
content yeah I mean is it crazy to just
have the left bar extended
no that's not completely crazy it seems
to me would that work Jeremy and others
I don't think it'll be enough it'll it
will help look an actor okay so I've got
another suggestion
what about extending the gray color
below the line to be down there but not
put another dentist and not put the
border is that a poor just and believe I
think I think we're guessing a little
too much all these things you have to
try just okay yes
people in a printed book it would look
like it would look like a misprint you
know yeah but it's not a printed book
that's that it's right maybe but get
away
various people suggesting centering and
I don't think that will work graphically
especially not if there are multiple
ones on the page and they don't line up
properly
um bullet in front of that I don't think
that will help I think that will look
like a section heading it'll be even
worse um and we are desperately avoiding
figure IDs so in fact I'm just writing a
document now that is is yeah anyway okay
should we go actually we have some
comments here which I'd like to respond
to what is this idea is this earth oh
that's back to the dates the revised
dates and just that one version up yeah
this one they're not to nitpick but
isn't that flipped from the introduced
then we've got year and then the version
and parens that's working under stress
it'll look fine it'll look fine when
that isn't um yeah it'll look fine
pull it going with the bullets yeah
going with the lips is 1.0 an exception
for the point like point your releases
know the the plenty of point really okay
well I mean six 6.0 get one like do you
get the point yes one just so what
you're saying I situation I see what
you're saying
I see what you're saying should we go
yeah yeah you could argue once just so
weird that you need it
no no why don't we go to point oh yeah I
don't see why not
is that in fact accurate Brian do we
actually know for like 2.0 versus two
point one versus two point two I think
we have that matter what year we have oh
yeah we know the years the story mind
whether they're whether there was a
release no no no no no I'm asking
whether a function was introduced in 2.2
or 2.1 actually two point one was a very
late release but it wasn't much in a 2.0
or 2.2
uh sometimes I think you know it's
whatever's in the source so it's
whatever was there but we do have we
actually recently had bill look through
the old book sources and find old new in
modified and tags for stuff dating
problem is this the problem is that his
theory that we didn't the reason that we
used integer numbers the problem is
because we didn't have a new book for to
point to the things that were in two
point two that were not in 2.0 didn't
make it into a visible documentation
release until the 3.0 book right dude
I'm saying the only place we could get
the two point two new function stuff is
the new and two point two flyers and
things which we certainly have I think I
think it's probably the right thing
Jeremy given all this discussion now
whatever let's put point O certainly for
the more recent ones point O the only
ones where we're going to be confused
about that is before six
right and before sex the point releases
were mostly not that big except for for
two point two which was big it's going
back a long way and four point two was
big yeah I thought there were a couple
but yeah with the date we can figure it
out all right fine
okay uh right um I'd say a few points on
our live stream here Ali says important
point functions like an maximize using
conic optimization and there was a stack
strange questions I'm going to mention
the method can be defined a good old
behavior I guess well this is the wrong
team to be discussing that this is
method documentation for and maximize I
mean we have a bunch of new method
documentation I don't know whether it's
for those functions
I think that's Brady that's something
for you to take to Roger and his team do
you know the status of the method
documentation because I know that we are
working on can anybody speak to that
documentation pages for methods I know
that I know that there have been a
number of them future eyes for years I
don't I don't know that I didn't realize
there's been more movement recently that
has and there's been a discussion of
forget for which functions of actually
having actual documentation pages for
methods and I think we should do it yeah
Gustavo mentions allowing comments and
the web version of documentation pages
we have a mechanism don't we for we have
feedback you can you can give us
comments and we also have on the agenda
user feedback is as helpful we have
something else we're going to talk about
with that too well we also have the the
users adding examples to pages what
happened to that project we mapped it
out and I still have all the notes we
just haven't kicked it off yet that
doesn't sound good okay we have a
backlog list I'll report it to you and
roadmap to okay
um okay
right so this was captions make it
italic at least
yeah the born at the bottom is italic
yeah below the gray bar yeah that's a
weird case that particular box is the
only one in the version one book that
was a one-column box almost all others
are at least two column but I think the
italic helps make it a feel caption like
yeah but but also these boxes have
separators in them that's not gonna work
the box is these two examples you've
shown are separate or less boxes many
boxes have separators right which is why
I feel like it could have the frame but
not the color the the caption should
also be indented more like you you see
how in your first example the caption
sort of aligns better than when you see
this bullet so we got to figure that out
as well I think this is gonna take more
effort and ya know getting it back
around around okay
talks example I can izing options that
are too long right this is something
that you asked about yeah via email um
these are just these are a couple
examples that I that make sense yeah
thing you know crazy salutely this focus
just totally bonkers yeah I saw that I
mean unless this is specifically well
this is specifically documenting grid so
maybe there's reasons to have this in
this particular case but generally let
me look here I mean yeah we were trying
to find examples where with the options
were not yeah I mean this one it's again
it's a plot 3d so these are plot 3d
options but but I agree that this would
perhaps not be I think that's distract I
think the mesh goes to none in the pond
style and all that stuff I think they
just distract from what you're trying to
show right because it has to be brain
cuts right exactly it's about branch
cuts not about plot styles
I can eyes all applaud style um in the
nationís all probably all of it I think
all of it together was the point was
just like I can eyes all the options
into just one flight all options here
yeah um a couple of things
Bob on our live stream is asking how do
we deal with version numbers versus
version you know what we've never had
this is one of those hacky things we've
I think in dollar version number we've
never had a
close to ten releases between two
integer races so we've never had the
issue of bad ordering of 12.12.2012 em
max amaizing intention should be updated
till the user to get the old
functionality
yes yeah that's terrible I don't know
why we don't have that I mean did this
wrong team to be discussing that with
that's Rogers team four and maximize it
could be a note for the incompatible
changes list no but also also it the
question is on the page and also why is
it the whole thing just sounds wrong to
me there should be a method arrow
classic or something like that
now legacy whatever just sounds wrong
but this is the wrong team we people
here don't know um so this I can eyes
business is more of a discussion point I
mean those two examples are illustrative
of what I think what we should do is do
a programmatic scan and then try and
hone the program based on which ones we
say yes that should be ionized no that
shouldn't be yeah I think that's true I
think at some point there's always gonna
have to be human involved though of
course there is yes the humor will have
to push the button but I think we can
programmatically scan for highly
optioned functions yeah that's kind of
where I was thinking this would probably
go the other thing that we might want to
ionize is things where we have you know
we could use examples that have more
data and that don't have to go to
example data to pick some data up which
would be nice
where we can just have an ionized thing
that just says example data as its as
its I can name get what I'm saying oh
yeah yeah yeah I think so so it would
just be something to find or and not
even find beforehand it could just be
right no no it's from the example but it
but it just be you know it would be
something like whatever it is um you
know like that which I think would look
really nice now something that's I've in
messing with I can eyes I think is still
missing is when you select something
right click I can eyes you can't name it
I thought that was getting fixed well
but I don't think there's any UI for
that is there like it's just well dot
dot dots it for you because I understand
that I understand that but I'm saying I
thought we had figured out a UX for that
oh maybe so and I
well why don't we check whether this I
agree that I remember talking about this
I thought we had figured it out I don't
know okay
mention waiting for you before you run
the the the human decision-making
process would that ultimately be enough
to inform a machine learning yeah our
only net if we if we elect these
examples we might be able to train and
would that neural net be able to I can
eyes for all users automatically while
they're coding that's really interesting
yeah that's an interesting idea and well
the hardest thing that I think about
this that the the thing that's gonna
most require curation is you have an
example that's illustrating a specific
option yeah you don't want to hike an
eyes that and I'm not sure if machine
learning might not be able to be subtle
enough to well it's a option beforehand
well yes if if we put the caption in
look that's a special case illustrating
an option if it's in the options section
it's kind of a different game but I do
think that that idea suggesting to
Brenton for the user assistance stuff
that that'd be a possibility is
interesting and not a code to me a
suggestion that you I can eyes it um
okay mentioning cloud in relation to
notebooks different notebook interfaces
this is really just like this just
content update cloud and some of our
older pages clouds not mentioned as has
to know real mention at all so like
under notebook interface there you know
it doesn't really say anything about
cloud should it
what the heck do you do in cloud there's
no save and save us because it's Auto
saving that could be a note well not on
this page it's prettier on page but that
particular note right but it's but for
other format pages right then you know
this is how you access this files of
this format use in the no communities
yes yes yes yes I mean one of the issues
here so what's the issue with this page
I mean that works in the cloud just fine
it's a little weird but you can
certainly do it sure I mean there's
nothing where you can run cloud but in
the cloud maybe what Brady's saying is
that this page doesn't actually talk
about that maybe it does but I see I see
that it would be worthwhile to mention
that yeah that's really what this point
is about is talking about the cloud more
in functions typically run from the
desktop oh well if we're gonna do that
we also should think about mobile and
touch and to face stuff which we also
have not systematically talked about I
mean you know we've had that
long-running project to put icons on
pages to indicate when three requisite
icons
okay so merge this with that well I
think so but the prerequisite icons are
such a mess as we realized when we
started doing them of you know is it a
private cloud is it a public cloud are
you logged in is it you know do you have
this do you have that um but I think I
think what may be the case there plenty
of functions that have no prerequisites
at all I mean it kind of reminds me of
those things you see on shipping
containers where it has a bunch of weird
icons you know don't tip this upside
down don't do this don't do that that's
kind of what what I had in mind but some
of those icons may be I mean I I don't
read the ones on shipping containers
enough but but you know I just kind of
wonder there's probably an icon that
means live animals inside and stuff like
this
um via which I probably never seen um
you know I haven't read a FedEx air bill
since FedEx was a new company a very
very very long time ago but when it was
a new company they had some wonderful
things on their bills about not shipping
live animals and so on um anyway who
knows um but ok so question is do we end
up what what has happened with the
prerequisites project it
it's been on hold why because it was to
cut difficult for money of content or
for some other reason yeah because the
people that we were involving like the
front end group in QA word or too busy
at the time I I want to kick it back off
for 12.2 what we just need to act early
on that because we'll have to touch all
of the authoring notebooks and we want
to do that before development it's like
really in swing well okay but do we
think we have the content no not yet
okay do we think the content is makeable
because I think what we had the trouble
we had before was as we tried to just
make an icon that says this works in the
cloud there's a lot of footnoting to
that see what I'm saying we had a cloud
with a slash through it a cloud with a
circle through it which means it sort of
worked in the cloud um others private
cloud only there's yeah and all the
different there's like requires Mouse
yeah I mean I I do have a list of some
of these things and one of the
challenges was figuring out who who's
kind of responsible for generating all
of this how we're gonna work through it
well right and unfortunately some of it
really requires a lot of footnoting you
know it's like well you know cuz you can
have a keyboard on a supposedly mobile
device for instance yeah so you know
it's not just a cloud and mobile type
thing or you know mobile versus desktop
type of story
it's do you have it you know because
mobile there are things that don't work
on mobile or do work on mobile like
geolocation is much more likely to work
on mobile than it is to work on
something else right I'm wondering
whether it's a textual thing whether
whether it is in fact the case that most
pages have no you know special
prerequisites at all but that we should
just have icons that mean there are
prerequisites associated with you know
mobile use or cloud use and the you
click it or something or you roll over
it and it tells you what the in text
what the story is I like that
like an asterisk yeah yeah and you only
see it you only expose it if you want to
see it well right yeah you don't right
but so what we need then is an icon that
means there's an issue with the cloud or
with whatever and click that to click
this thing to find out what the issue is
right I think that's where we should go
because I think before me trying to have
of these orthogonal icons for everything
that just wasn't working um comment from
Bob on our live stream such kind of
interesting is the question of could
there be well in a sense we already have
this actually I mean could there be a
form of like um
you
you
you
you know when you get that as output
I see the problem is that you don't know
whether you want to give that form the
question is you know in a sense output
already uses the analog of eicken
ization we've got a whole lot of other
stuff coming in terms of illusion of
output and being able to click on things
things going beyond the two big
indicator um by the way I'm Bailey can
you make sure it should be on the user
assistance main user assistance agenda
although I don't think we even get to it
immediately but we have had a bunch of
discussion about elided output and I
don't think that's on the current
development priorities list okay and
there's several things ahead of it okay
let's go on to this oh I hate these
things
Oh - well you do what is this helpful I
don't know what do you do do you ever
click that I do I do when I'm mad I only
ever say no I never say yes if that
makes sense
okay anybody else in this meeting do you
click it I would've fiercely ignore them
I guess that answers that I mean I don't
know I'd be interested maybe it's
generational
who who here is young and does oh does
not ignore these I'm under 40 and I
ignore them I don't know if that counts
as young I guess it's just me Steven but
is that what you would like me to do I
could just kind of survey people well
you talk about their parents still here
right I let her know boss what would we
do if people just said no no no what
would we do if they said yes yes yes do
we give their author a gold star if they
say yes the whole bunch I mean what
happens when you click no do we have any
of these like in these two examples
Google's just goes away I look at the
whole section just disappears
once you say yes or no and then hours
when you say yes or no you get the
option of adding a comments yeah let's
you know that's useful and what well
let's find out if anybody ever commented
on them okay I'll do that
I'll bring it back later that that
iconography is so old we must have had
these for at least 15 years so we must
have a lot of comments on a lack of
comments so let's get that data you
could have it say was this helpful or
not and then have it say yes okay
internally the link we've got various
people a live stream there is
identifying various ages one person over
70 identifying but there was this
helpful as useless
[Laughter]
streaming this there's like people
commenting during the meeting Hidy Hidy
Hidy explaining that to everybody
um so in you mentioned do you remember
this I do remember this this is a this
is an issue let me take the example what
was the example that I had originally
picked I don't know he didn't pass along
this was through Matt and what Matt said
was different than what I understood
from your clarification so I mean I know
there are a bunch of old screenshots in
like the old Sisson Minh guide like
installing math at one oh no that's no
gosh that's an unbelievably useless page
look at that pathetic what the heck is
this that's a pathetic level of um that
is a totally inadequate piece of
documentation look at that is it
everything about it or just the example
the others no examples and it doesn't
tell you how to put where's the list of
tags something's missing here this can't
possibly be right
oh oh no I know what it was maybe sorry
let me try this I forgotten where this
was okay so look there were things in
here that were version 10 Mathematica
version 10 screenshots okay I mean
greens lots of notebooks that have the
notebook window of elements that say
Mathematica 10 or whatever right that's
what yes that's what I'm talking about
so and this isn't great because that's
probably gonna get redone so what I'm
saying is you need to have tagging for
whether these screenshots and sadly you
know you got to go through and remake
them yeah
but first thing is to have tagging well
you see at the top it's already been
given a generic appearance so if we just
didn't have that cloud banner at the
bottom that would have been fine as a
you know fairly generic look yes well
it's generic until the world changes and
you know people no longer have
skeuomorphic this that and the other
yeah right oh they have a you know I
mean these things will change Styles
will change notebook put is a page with
something like what you're talking about
yeah that's absolutely horrifying
it's crazy that we have that there and
these menus might change you know change
will happen in these UI elements we
might change the fonts you know so if we
are able to get it generated
programmatically we should do that like
that hundred percent thing might very
well train you mean it's just like
I mean the the chrome around the window
doesn't really matter that much
it could be genericized sort of like
what we did with the web screens you
know what you know what we could do we
have a genericized notebooks before I
think there might have been a reason why
we didn't do these but we have done it
for others yeah unless I mean one
possibility is it's a complete fake that
is the thing that's generated here is a
symbolic representation of the notebook
and we simply have agent have a a
late-stage renderer for the notebook
that we could subsequently change so I'm
saying so in other words none of these
are actually screenshots but I think
there are things which have to be
screenshots what whatever we do there's
going to be documentation pages and
service-connection where it's a
screenshot of you know the Facebook API
login page or something and it's just
we've got to tag these and we've got to
look at them every release and try and
make sure that they're still up to date
I don't think there are that many of
them right and in the little background
color is intentional
yeah I'm not helped and these are tagged
I believe so okay well fine so they
don't you can look at them
okay it's just not been as solid part of
our checklists so I'm fine okay
programmatic conclusion in the docs this
is an important one I am so fed up with
seeing things like the settings are the
same as in whatever I mean that's pure
laziness on the part on our part I mean
we can still say the settings are the
same as in gone out :
below there they are now how do we do
that yeah well straight up duplication
is not a good idea I'm aware but I'm
until my question is could we have
something look the way to do this is to
put some kind of thing in the source
notebook for let's say graphics 3d
that is a harvestable yeah I mean this
is like a form notebook play
it's a harvestable tag for the cell that
contains that table
am i making sense I I know what you mean
the this you're talking about that plot
3d graphics 3d business the problem with
that is that you've got you have to
merge two tables you know it says plot
3d has the same options as graphics 3d
with the following additions and then it
lists it has its own table well then why
don't we what does that to say has has
the following special options in
addition it supports all the options of
graphics 3d blah
do what I'm saying yeah sure sure I mean
I see what you're saying it's just that
it's not always gonna be just a straight
drop Lathon illustrating well okay then
we should have an intersperse mechanism
then we could have something which is
look and we got two cases if they're
alphabetized we know how to intersperse
them right
I mean sometimes there'll be a little
bit of a problem with wording but it's
you know we'll have to smooth that over
I think we got to do this I mean and we
we've some have been copied by hand we
polish should find those and get rid of
the copies
i braid II was pointing out before some
of the cloud pages have very very
similar if not the same options tables
throughout you know their function pages
and I could assume that was done by hand
right well anyway I think this is a
mechanism we need I mean I don't see any
justification for sending people to
another page you know the same as on
blah blah blah the same is just say it
here and by the way sometimes it's not
an options table sometimes it's
something else it's a piece of text
I mean I don't know what anybody
disagrees the the only reason we did
that was 30 whatever it is now 32 years
ago now 31 years ago now you know this
was in you know a lot of this material
was in a printed book and we just want
burning trees so to speak we didn't want
to use more paper right so we we wanted
to shorten it with things like that but
there's no justification for that on the
web or in online stuff in general
yeah well as long as yeah with accepting
the holes keeping things in sync but
once that's worked out then I agree
okay cross-linking
what is this this tutorial guide
crosslink right so this was something
that uh we talked about I think last
time the context of this was updating
the tech note contents those those tech
notes that were perhaps two out of date
this was a a sort of precursor project
to those updates which was finding those
cross fighting cross links from tech
notes to guide pages and then that would
tell us what functions were missing from
those tech notes and then I'd say it
would be it give us some indicator of
how much work it would be to update that
tech know what they owned well this data
is it just came in just got that and so
it needs to be processed but but that
was day's latest focus and so I wanted
to make sure to give an update on
cross-linking okay the the more
important cut is the stuff to do with
symbols and non function ref pages yes
yes that's the previous opener but
that's on this list too oh I didn't
symbols
back forth to entities and you had
looked at those before and and like
Brian had said earlier in roadmap we we
need to get you a list but I already
have a special meeting set up with you I
think on the week after next yeah
to to review them built us see also so
that you can sanity check them and make
sure they're not maybe something less
programmatic by right it would be form
it would be built and formatted this is
just the raw data of course okay fine
and we actually need there are some I
have some ideas on trimming this down
because these lists are in many cases
too long by design okay good thumbnail
openers very nice so where are their
pacifiers and bedding Matheson so there
are methods so there are those are I
think those are machine learning the
machine learning methods yeah okay so
there are Method documentation pages
they just don't happen to be method
documentation pages for chronic
optimization but probably there should
be for method documentation pages
yes yes but I don't think they're the
same methods that we're talking about
you know these aren't right hand sides
to the method option these are you know
let me think about let me find an
example came out an 11-3 I can sorry I I
shouldn't be looking to check out I
should be looking in the installation
layout
yeah one's gradient boosted trees I can
put it in the chat okay so yeah ref
slash method slash gradient boosted
trees or follow the link that Brady put
in the zoom shot great so that should be
I don't understand why we can't have
exactly the same thing for the
optimization functions maybe Roger
doesn't know that these pages exist I
mean is there are these in fact you do
classify of blah blah blah comma method
all right well fine so then oh yeah well
all right fine so yeah cool then we have
a little arrow sized a little bit
because obviously not all of them are
machine learning methods all of them
though I think we currently have in now
our machine I understand that but so it
should say things like oh you know
numeric computation I mean it depends
what it is optimization method for
example yeah yeah I would imagine the
reason it says machine learning method
is applicable to a range of functions
not just classifier predict but a whole
bunch of things or I don't do my I'm not
sure if that's true but anyway um yeah
okay well it doesn't say as much it
that's fine um anyway you see those
where the thumbnails are you see where
they need to come sounds good okay
dynamic pagination that's really
important it has yes agreed in title
parens for rollin on function play oh I
know what that is yes
jumped example in options tables but
I'll anchor you down to the example with
that option right so right now there are
the example links that we may have are
really small and hard to see I think
that was that's the point here right
Brady was that this was to call those
out a little better yeah okay graphic
subjects remaining icons okay
tooltips for examples categories what's
that we talked about them with you once
before but we've gotten some user
feedback that the the headings are
category categorization of the examples
isn't always clear what defines in
relations mean for example purses yeah
but eat I and and Brett's brought some
text suggestions to Roger so I'm waiting
to hear back on those and then I'll
bring them to you with more context okay
okay
alright we don't have a backlog section
here which means I have no visibility
into what we're not doing
I will add a backlog section and I I
mean gosh like for example you guys are
not involved in guide pages for the
functional posit or is that correct I
mean I did a little bit of mock-up work
for your physics page guide but not not
more directly than that they haven't
bobbin etc have not directly talked to
me anyway about function repository
guide pages okay I can reach out to them
if well yes I mean okay that's sir and
and the the next issue is the
consumerization of ducky tools is that I
think having the other lifestyle meaning
on that first day oh okay I want us to
prepare for that in particular I mean
it's it's worth noting that the attendee
list for that meeting is pretty
extensive we
got John and Todd and I think our node
and it I think it might make sense to
turn that more into a packet repository
meeting because that's well the question
of reorientation tools be look look the
fact is no I mean the fact is people
wanted yeah okay fair enough I mean
people want to document stuff they want
documentation that is buildable for the
web they want documentation you know all
the things that we now have a pretty
clean junior version of that I mean look
I've been writing function repository
items okay and I would say that um you
know these tools are pretty good for my
purposes yeah for function pages
certainly and and you know we've got we
actually have a pretty polished up you
know palette driven documentation tools
that will be prepared to show and it's
it's a packet that it's the interface
for it is based off of the old workbench
version but the code driving it is you
know the code driving current docket
tools okay but I mean donkey tools must
have a thousand buttons on it
yeah the version that we're looking at
has a small fraction of these buttons by
design you know now that also means that
there are fewer capabilities but you
know that's I mean I think many of these
capabilities I think an interesting
question would be to inventory which of
these capabilities from documentation
writers and so on which do you actually
use and we have yeah that was my first
request okay good so what's the answer I
mean we trimmed down a number of tools
but that's right we did trim down a
number of things I mean if you collapse
all these sections you'll see that for
example all of the content types of the
you know future the stuff that's future
tentative there used to be a whole
rainbow of buttons down there you know
you can still get them but now at least
they're hidden that was a you know small
usability improvement though the most
visible because there's no more rainbow
on the page but also rearranging some
buttons and dropping some that either
didn't work or didn't make sense and we
had no document it to which I have no
idea what that um cloud examples in it I
mean there's all kinds of weird stuff
here and and all these weird renaming
things which should be I mean there's a
useful but probably not really useless
eternally yeah
and that Bell of course be stripped and
you know we're not gonna doll there's
not a no tab for example you know all
that Oh tab stuff maybe we want to
expose some of it someday but for
version 1 of documentation tools no need
obviously no marketing tab you know so
it's if you want to see it I can point
you to it or I can have it in a Viraj
air install it I know I'm a little leery
about that because it might connect the
sake tools because I don't know it's not
do it ok anything else yeah nope so okay
good stuff alright talk till soon thanks
bye normal of stream